[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to your first look at the retail
shipping packages for the iphone 8 and
the iphone 8 plus so these things are
about to start shipping and these are
the boxes you can see uh the little
glass details on the front and there's
only three colors of this phone right
off the bat silver which we have this
new gold which we'll get into and space
gray
no red and no jet black at least this
time around for right now but the small
detail you may have noticed uh the box
for this new gold colored iphone which
i'll call it like a blush gold is
actually not white it's an off-white
like the cream color on the back of the
phone so the more you know but either
way let's dig into the iphone 8 first so
it's a pure white box and you get your
paperwork up top above the phone and
then the iphone itself so pretty much
identical to last year
so here's the glass backed wireless
charging iphone in all its moderately
new glory but we'll put that to the side
for a second to look at the accessories
it comes with which surprise are exactly
the same as last year i swear this is an
iphone 7s a wall adapter earpods the
lightning audio dongle and your
lightning charging cable okay great so
let's look at this this new colored
phone this new gold for the iphone 8
plus in its cream-colored box and
copper-colored accents and all that
again has the paperwork on the top which
is actually still white so not cream
hopefully you can see that it's kind of
hard to show on camera but then of
course you get the iphone itself white
front again both these lighter colored
phones have the white front only the
space gray iphone 8 has the black front
bezels
so long story short these both look very
familiar because they're super similar
to last year in design the glass back is
new obviously but you have identical
dimensions to iphone 7 so any cases you
have from that phone will also work with
these and most of the changes are on the
inside and the spec bump so let's fire
this one up i actually went through the
setup process for ios 11 and it was
mostly the same with putting in my sim
card and signing into wi-fi and apple's
accounts and all stuff like that the one
thing that was new was true tone so you
can choose now to turn right on the true
tone color display right out the box or
not which is pretty cool of course you
can always adjust that later so i flew
through everything and once i finished
one of the first apps i wanted to take a
look at like last year was geekbench and
geekbench 4 here says iphone 8 plus with
the a11 bionic chip has three gigs of
ram again compared to the six or eight
gigs that we're seeing in some android
phones now but we did that cpu benchmark
and it did pretty damn well as you can
see so it comes out with a comparable
multi-core score to the snapdragon 835
in this note 8 but a massive single core
score which is awesome for everyday
activities like dinking around the user
interface and quick animations and
things like that so that's good to see
and you also might notice the iphone's
display looking a little warmer here
here is the toggle for the true tone
display responsible for that on iphone
8. me flipping the switch here doesn't
make a huge difference on the camera
since my video lighting is pretty much
on point but the true tone will make a
bigger difference in places like
outdoors or with more harsh lighting so
that's something we'll explore more in
the full review but that's pretty much
what's new with the iphone 8 first
experience i think the best way to
appreciate the slightly new design is to
have it next to the same color iphone 7
which you can see had since its metal
like a bit more texture to the aluminum
back you can actually feel the cutout
for the apple logo where on the iphone 8
this new one it's more under the glass
so you can't feel it by running your
finger over it and also there's no fcc
markings on the bottom of the new iphone
which is why it looks cleaner
and it's just a bit heavier feeling
because glass is after all a heavier
material than metal but yeah i guess
what i'm really trying to figure out is
is this new gold a good color i mean i
mentioned it in one of the previous
videos the gold kind of looks
i think pale in the middle is the word
the glass to me it kind of looks a
little bit light like the rails on the
side where it's still metal i definitely
kind of like that it's a gold medal the
ring around the home button and the ring
around the camera cut out it's a new
look but then the middle of the back
just looks so sandy i don't know i think
i would stick with the silver or space
gray on this one but that's up to you
let me know what you think
full review is coming soon and also
iphone 10 coverage when that's available
but until then hit that subscribe button
thank you for watching and i'll talk to
you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]